the traditional way of doing things is
that you set aside chunks of time and
you get focused and get things done and
that's how all our tasks are designed
and that would work except for the fact
that just finding the chunk of time to
focus it's difficult what we do have is
these little bits and pieces of moments
they are scattered throughout the day
and we said what if we defrag all of
those moments and we get something
substantial done the idea is that you
take a task you break it down into
smaller chunks and then you can kind of
scatter those tasks throughout your day
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if you've recently found it more
difficult to focus your attention for a
lengthy stretch of time in order to get
a complex task done or worse found it
difficult even to find a lengthy stretch
of time in which to try you're not alone
and actually you're in luck dr. Chauncey
Iqbal a senior researcher in the
information and data Sciences group at
Microsoft Research wants to help you
manage your attention better and be more
productive at the same time and she's
using technology to do it on today's
podcast dr. Iqbal tells us about her
work in the field of micro productivity
a line of research that takes aim at the
short spurts of time she calls micro
moments that we otherwise might have
considered too short to get anything
useful done she also explains why
distraction can be good for us and gives
us some advice on how to make the most
of our cognitive resources whether by
setting aside time to tackle big tasks
in the traditional wedding or by
breaking them down into micro tasks and
outsourcing them to ourselves that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Chauncy Iqbal welcome to the podcast
thank you as a senior researcher in the
information and data Sciences group at
Microsoft Research your work revolves
around attention management for
multitasking domains I'm intrigued
already in general because they'll get
specific in a second give us a little
more detail about the work you do and
why you do it what gets you up in the
morning well that's a fun topic to talk
about I get up in the morning
mentally reciting all the things that I
need to do that day that's probably most
of us do the fun part is that that's
exactly what I get to do for my research
and basically what I'd look at is how
can we help people better manage their
attention in a situation where they're
dealing with multiple interruptions that
are coming from many competing entities
right you know what the fun part is is
whenever I talk about this research with
someone they get it it resonates with
them and they come to me and say oh yeah
how can your research help me be more
productive and manage my attention
better so there's a lot of pressure to
get it right are you a list person no
not really
is it all in your head yeah that's where
the problem is and so when I say not
really it's something that I'm forcing
myself to do and I find it to be more
useful than before and what I've
actually started doing is not only
putting it down on a piece of paper I
have started putting it on my whiteboard
at work so that it's not only me who
looks at it it's other people and it's
some kind of accountability that if I
don't have it crossed off for a long
time someone is going to come and point
it out oh yeah you had this thing on the
whiteboard that said well review this
paper November and it's now May and you
haven't reviewed this paper well I want
to start out by talking about a couple
of buzz words that seemed to pervade the
literature in your research area and
first let's zoom in on multitasking
for a second I've read papers especially
a famous one by Cliff Nass at Stanford
that says there's actually no such thing
as multitasking what we're actually
doing is task slicing or task switching
and I'm sure there's camps here or
nuance maybe as a better word but give
us your take on multitasking since
that's sort of the focus of your
research how does how we think about
this effect what we do about it well
there are two schools of thought here
and I'm gonna channel theories from
psychology and more specifically
theories of cognition so there is one
definition that says exactly what you
said is that people are not doing things
in parallel they're doing things
serially and what is happening is that
they're very rapidly switching their
attention and this is from the idea of
single channel theory so you have this
part of cognitive resources and whenever
you're doing a task you're dipping into
that pot and you are switching back and
forth between tasks and so you are
basically putting in resources and
getting them out of it now there's also
a less restrictive Theory called
multiple resources theory where you have
different parts yo you might have a part
for your auditory resources you'll have
a part for your visual resources and in
that case you're able to do things in
parallel when your tasks demand
different types of resources so you
might be able to do a visual task and an
auditory task at the same time because
they're dipping into separate parts now
the problem is that most of our tasks
are not strictly auditory or strictly
visual so that's where the conflicts
start coming in there's also the
automaticity theory so where things are
so automatic for you is that you really
don't need to put in a lot of conscious
thought into it and those happen without
you really needing a lot of cognitive
resources like driving exam and you end
up someplace and you don't remember how
you got there yes it's kind of dangerous
but think about things like we walk and
talk at the same time right so we're not
thinking about how to walk because
that's so ingrained in us so we can just
basically walk and keep on talking
without any performance degradation in
either of those tasks
but from a more practical point of view
when you talk about multitasking in the
real world we are essentially talking
about serial tasking and we are rapidly
switching our attention across those
tasks well so drilling in a little bit
there this idea of you can't do multiple
things at once that we know actually you
can because like you mentioned walk and
talk or you know you're stirring
something in your kitchen and listening
to something right so it's all these
multi-sensory things that are happening
however moving over to the kind of
current classic definition of
multitasking is the kid who says I can
do my homework and be snapchatting at
the same time you can't I mean you might
be able to you're not going to be able
to do quality work on either of those
I'm glad to know that because I can't do
that and I always thought if somebody
else could what do they have that I
don't have it's just impossible
all right so every time your kid tells
you I can do this all at the same time
you say research says you can't Shawn C
says you can't I wish I could tell that
to my kids well let's talk about another
buzzword which is fragmentation and in
some of our conversations I've heard you
use the phrase defrag on my very first
podcast my guest was Jamie Tevan and I
asked her this question and I'd like to
ask you two same question why do you
think things are so fragmented today and
how is it different from what we might
call bad attention spans in previous
eras is it different that's a good
question so the way that I think of
fragmentation is it's a consequences of
us wanting to do multiple things at the
same time so essentially what is
happening is that we want to be able to
focus on one thing but there's so many
external things that are demanding our
attention that we end up with having
these little fragments of attention and
so that's basically what fragmented
attention is it's not necessarily a bad
thing but we're in this odd space where
we are trying to get tasks done that are
designed for focused attention and all
we have in most of the cases is these
little bits and pieces of attentional
of fragments is there any literature on
fragmentation prior to this era of
high-tech distraction so psychology
literature has been looking at attention
for many many years and there is not
only the high-tech distraction or the
external distraction there's also the
self distraction so where we are having
difficulties in prioritizing what should
be at the focus of our attention
I mean in theory we should be doing
certain things and we want to optimize
what we do in order to be more
productive but in practice what we end
up doing is not necessarily optimal
right so as you doing the research here
at Microsoft Research and you're dealing
with high tech solutions to this problem
of fragmentation are you drawing on any
of that you know sort of decades old
psychological literature and or any
theory oh absolutely I mean that is what
I feel that drives my research a lot is
that I'm a computer scientist by
training so I had no background in
psychology but I went back and I read up
on these theories because I feel that
that helps explain a lot of things and
how we do them and why we do them in a
certain way going back to your question
we have to adapt to this new way of how
things happen or how we are getting
interrupted and that's where the
psychology theories or the understanding
comes in and one of my goals is to help
develop technology to provide the
solution
[Music]
I want to ask you about the word that
pops up in your research a lot right now
which is productivity and it's hard to
define and measure oh yeah but as a
researcher you have to be working from
some sort of baseline so I think you
said we're not machines to be measured
by maximum output per unit of time but
it often seems like we're trying to
reach some kind of accomplishment
nirvana
or something and employ technology to
help us get there yep so what do you
think about that and how do you
operationalize to use a classic
researcher term the word productivity in
the context of your work so yeah the
industry definition of productivity that
you just mentioned I mean it covers only
so much of it and we ourselves have been
debating about what does productivity
actually mean because for an information
worker a lot of the work is so I mean
it's not necessary tangible or
measurable I spent two hours reading a
paper right it helps me improve my
knowledge but how do you put a number to
it how do you measure that and so that's
true for many of the things that we do
is that the outcome is not externally
visible so in our research what we have
done a lot is that we just ask people we
asked them how productive they feel the
other thing that we do look at is that
there's some external measures I mean
you can look at time people are spending
on productivity applications how many
things on their to-do lists are they
getting done the quality of their work
maybe but it's still up in the air a
little bit and we are working hard
towards coming up with the definition of
productivity for information workers
we're still doing that so is that the
focus then is information workers as
your target audience kind of so that is
a big target audience but I mean using
computers and devices is not only
limited to information workers I mean
you look around you and everyone has
multiple devices they're using they're
constantly getting in
corrupted their attention is fragmented
I'm using the word fragmented again I
love it so I think that this these
findings are basically generalizable to
the general population yeah
some people claim we're living in an
attention economy yeah we're distraction
is the new normal and focus is the new
coin of the realm and we could lament
our collective short attention span or
try harder to reclaim our ability to be
single-minded but you're taking a
different tack by using technology to
help us coexist with distraction and
still get stuff done right so why do you
think your approach is necessary because
the other one is putting the genie back
in the bottle right so well the word
destruction has a negative connotation
to it and I want to look at it
differently because sometimes you do
need to step away from work and you do
need to take breaks and you do need to
just refresh your perspectives and I
believe that that actually makes you
more productive in the long run so I
think that the problem is deeper here so
we need to take breaks we need to do
other stuff but we have difficulties in
prioritizing what is important for us
what we need to get done what moves us
forward in the responsibilities that we
have and we often get lost and I think
that's where technology can help us I
mean if I'm not able to help myself
because I am just distractible and when
I go down that rat hole of distractions
then maybe yes I do need something that
pulls me back out and so that's how we
are coming at this problem because I
personally don't feel that if you take a
break and you go and chat with a
colleague about mundane things or if I
go on Facebook or Twitter
unless I'm spending hours on it I don't
see that to be a problem right let's
talk about some of your earlier work I
love digging into research history
because it always informs current work
so I'd like to go back to a paper you
wrote with the illustrious Eric Horvitz
in 2007 where you highlight the concern
around what you guys called the chain of
diversion this can occur when you take a
break from your work whether intentional
or not and you find yourself so far
the rabbit hole that you can't even
remember what you were doing what is the
science tell us about these diversions
especially in terms of focus and
recovery time and what research ideas
have emerged since then to help us
mitigate the gravitational pull of
infinite scroll as I would call it yeah
so this was work that I did as an intern
in 2006 so 13 years ago smartphones
weren't a thing then so what we were
looking at is just basically one device
or one machine a laptop or a desktop and
what people did on that single machine
we were very interested in notifications
and what happens when email notification
pops up because it's that trigger for
you to switch attention or an iamb
notification pops up because you know
someone is waiting on the other end for
your response and we wanted to see what
happens and so that is what led to us
characterizing this chain of direction
which was interesting because you feel
that you know what is going on but when
you see it in real data that really pops
out and so what we found is that well a
notification often important it pulls
you to email so you go and check your
outlook and once you have disengaged
from that path that you're working on
it's kind of like an open invitation to
go and be further distracted so one
email leads to the next one and then
maybe you go and check your personal
email maybe now that you're on a browser
so you might go and browse and then 15
to 18 minutes have passed and this is
something that we actually found and
then you realize if you're lucky that
you actually had some other work that
you were doing that you need to get back
to and now the challenge is that you
have to figure out what you're doing so
you were all tabbing across all the open
applications and then when you land on
the one that you finally realize that
okay so this is the document that I was
working on
then you need to recreate that context
so basically all of what I described
right after you decide that yes I need
to return that's the resumption time and
so that's one of the key metrics that we
use in measuring interrupt ability and
so the problem now is
even worse right so you now have
multiple devices you have your phone you
have many multiple machines that you're
working on and multiple entities that
are demanding our attention and so
you're switching back and forth so we
haven't quite quantified that yet but
we'll see so this is the world we're
living in and the world you're helping
us try to navigate and sometimes
mitigate let's talk in more detail about
the work you're doing now and I would
give it the broad umbrella of micro
productivity and how you and your
colleagues are asking questions about
snippets of time or micro moments as you
call them to help us take advantage of
otherwise quote/unquote wasted time and
in the process free us up to do longer
stretches of time on things we want to
do what's your work about and how do I
make micro moments work for me so yeah
so I'm gonna take you back to probably
2013 when Jamie Tevan and I first
started looking at this and we came from
the point of view that we're not going
to be able to stop the multiple stream
of informations that people have to
process and they have to switch their
attention across so we basically have to
find a way that we can adapt to this new
normal the traditional way of doing
things is that you set aside chunks of
time and you get focused and get things
done and that's how all our casts are
designed and that would work except for
the fact that just finding the chunk of
time to focus it's difficult what we do
have is these little bits and pieces of
moments they're scattered throughout the
day and we said what if we defrag all of
those moments and we get something
substantial done the idea is that you
take a task you break it down into
smaller chunks and then you can kind of
scatter those tasks throughout your day
so you have five minutes before a
meeting maybe you can get ten of those
tasks done and maybe you have two
minutes which is really not enough to do
anything but you could get a couple of
to do's off your plate
this takes forethought in order to break
down the desks that you have and so how
do you get to the point where you could
actually break that or am I getting
ahead of myself and that's what your
research is hell I guess a good to know
I think you have the right question
because when we started this line of
research that's one of the challenges
that we had is that we cannot expect
that people are going to break down
their own tasks so as part of our
solution we need to have a way of
creating these workflows so if you take
a complex task and there is a way that
you could break it down into a series of
smaller subtasks and then for the end
user all they see is these micro tests
that are popping up at different moments
they don't have to worry about how to
break them down our system or our
framework is going to do that for them
so what kinds of tasks can be broken
down in the way that you are describing
that's a great question and we assume
that most tasks could be and again
there's some psychology backing of this
as well there is this idea called task
unitization and this goes back to the
70s where researchers had people look at
videos of people doing physical tasks
like folding laundry or mowing the lawn
and asked them to write down exactly
what is happening so when you ask people
to look at the unit tasks so they're
basically coming up with a series of
very small actions and that's what we
wanted to get at now in terms of more
information work tasks if you think of
using micro-moments we are already doing
some of it we do a lot of communication
tasks they are mostly discrete and not
part of a bigger tasks we were
interested in okay let's pick up complex
tasks such as writing because no one
thinks of writing in terms of micro
tasks we wanted to take that challenge
and say can we break down writing tasks
into smaller sub tasks so that at least
some of these are things that we could
do in micro moments so imagine that you
need to add a citation to your writing I
mean you don't really need focus time
for that you could get a bunch of those
and get them done in your free time
right
there are other tasks as well for
example correcting grammar or spelling
but it took us a while to get to that
point is there what makes sense there
are also things like information
gathering so if I'm writing I mean I
need to get some information from our
website so I might do that as a micro
task and in some sense it helps with
your focus as well so if I am sitting
there focusing on my writing and then
suddenly oh yeah I need to grab these
numbers if I switch at that moment that
basically means that I am opening myself
up to a chain of diversion
I would rather postpone that little
action right as a micro task that I can
get back to later and continue with my
focused writing well it takes a
tremendous amount of self-awareness but
I'm pretty certain that people do add
these inline notes when they're writing
I mean at least I do and I wouldn't
characterize myself as the most
organized person when I'm writing but I
do insert these in light notes because I
don't want to interrupt the flow along
those lines tell us about this tool that
you've developed called play write which
is actually a funny play on words
perspective it's a technical tool that
breaks certain tasks down into smaller
ones which would be helpful for me
all right so how does it work where you
use it and what have you found as a
result of your research with this tool
so as you said it is an interesting play
of the word so we wanted to have the
word play in it because we wanted the
interactions to be playful and game-like
and again this is an instantiation of
micro tasks writing or micro writing and
it's a framework basically which
interacts with Microsoft Word it will
analyze your Word document it will
extract micro tasks out of it and these
are just all basically writing micro
tasks it could be something as simple as
spelling Corrections which is a very
context-free task and it takes you about
two seconds to get it done or
grammatical Corrections or triaging
comments and those kinds of things and
we started off with a small list of
tasks which can be of course expanded
it extracts those puts them on the cloud
and then through a mobile app you can
access those tasks and it's designed in
a way that you could just interact with
these in a game-like fashion you could
play games like let's see how many tests
we could do in five minutes or two
minutes or let me finish all the tasks
on this document and then later it gets
integrated back into your Word document
so essentially you're making progress
when you're away from your document with
very little cognitive engagement or time
comment right so I want to circle back
just more 10,000 foot view on this idea
of micro productivity and micro tasks
and micro moments have you found this to
resonate with the people that you bring
into research I think it all depends on
the framing one of the concerns that
people have is that oh my god you are
ruining my free time you're going to
make me work all the time and that's not
the goal at all so one of the goals or I
would say the major goal is to actually
save people time so since just finding
focus time is so difficult what we're
essentially trying to do is to get
people to do things or tasks in these
short bursts with the hope that it will
amount to an outcome that you would have
gotten if you had similar focused time
and our dream is that through this we
could probably save people an hour and
then maybe you can go home an hour early
and spend time on other things that is
not work
[Music]
one area of lost time that we can all
relate to is drive time in our commutes
to and from work but you've even got a
Productivity hacking idea for that but
tell us about your work on speech based
productivity support in the car what
kinds of studies have you done so far
and what conclusions have you drawn to
date on this idea this is a fun topic
and this is probably the topic that we
get the most discussions and the
feedback and back and forth on so I mean
we have done many years of research with
Eric Orbitz looking at how people do
tasks when they are driving a car and
these projects are using driving
simulators so no one was harmed during
these experiments or hands exactly but
we've been trying to characterize how
people do tasks and one of the
interesting findings there is that
driving is mostly automated and there
are opportunities for people to actually
interleave an on driving task if I go
back to my original point about parts of
cognitive resources when driving is so
automated that you really don't have to
think about it you do have some
cognitive resources that are left over
that you could make use of I'm gonna
flip the question I'm gonna ask you so
when you're in a car there's a passenger
in the car how many times on average do
you speak to that person all the time
there you go and I would imagine that
most people would interact with in
vehicle controls they're trying to play
on the radio they're trying to set the
temperature and I mean there are tons of
other non driving tasks that people
engage in what I'm saying is that we do
have this cognitive resource residue or
leftovers that we could potentially use
and what we try to look at is that well
if a person is having a conversation on
a car and let's assume that it is a
phone conversation using Bluetooth
they're able to have that
conversation but they are very careful
in interleaving it safely so they would
talk for a bit they would make sure that
they are driving properly they would
talk for a bit again and these are again
driving simulator studies so we saw an
opportunity there and based on the micro
tasking or the micro productivity
progress that we have made we wanted to
push the boundaries a little further and
here we are we have these long commute
times so we wanted to kind of like come
up with this concept is that well I mean
intelligent assistance is becoming a
thing and Siri and Cortana and Alex ADIZ
will soon make their ways into our cars
to help us do things via speed and so
how can we leverage these technologies
to actually get things done in the car
right so our goal was can we capture
people's thoughts and can we push it a
little further can we do something as
far as creating a document or a
PowerPoint via speech and the
interactions that we wanted to test out
is that you have this intelligent system
that will ask you a bunch of questions
at opportune moments during driving
and when I say opportune moments that
means that when it feels that you're
able to engage with those questions and
these questions are super short will
take a few seconds are context free so
you don't really have to think a lot to
answer them and once you put together
all the information that is gathered
that can be saved as a draft of a
document or on a slide so that's the
study that we did in the driving
simulator so we Wizard of Oz dis which
is basically an experimenter was behind
a technology that was interacting with
drivers when they were driving on a
really simple route and at the same time
they were asked to interact with this
agent that would ask them questions to
which they provide the answers and
eventually that turns into a document or
a PowerPoint deck that agent at the same
time would also alert them towards
different driving scenarios
and so it would point out that while
there is a speed bump coming up or you
need to make a left turn so it will make
sure that you are focusing on the road
it would also pull back in the
interactions whenever the road
conditions became dicey that's
interesting I would think even if it
didn't make its way into you know cars
that we drive today it would certainly
be useful in a self-driving car
mercilessly where you aren't required to
have as much absolutely and and that was
also one of our motivations behind this
I mean even though you're not driving
it's still not your office it's still an
attention elite challenged environment
we will keep on getting interrupted so
you still need to design tasks in a
different way so that you're able to
attend to them differently than you
would do in a secluded office I'm really
intrigued by this research because the
idea that I could you know when you're
driving sometimes you have an idea and
you want to write it down but you can't
write or you do and yeah well so this
was why I was motivated to do this
research is that I have about a
30-minute commute during rush hour and I
have all these thoughts that are
floating through my mind and it actually
does take away my ability to focus on
the road so wouldn't it be great if
there is a way that we could capture
these thoughts easily so that I have
them out of my head
recorded somewhere I don't have to worry
about them until I get to my destination
I hope you're successful on this
research hopefully so he's out but we'll
see but the interesting thing is what we
found is that people were really they
found it to be useful what they found
really useful is the added alerts that
the system was pointing them towards
different things on driving that they
should be focusing on we also saw
compensatory behaviors so people right
at the beginning they would slow down so
that they had reasonable headway
distance with the car in front so that
they wouldn't crash into it and so
people already have these kinds of
behaviors but what was also interesting
is that if the questions were
unpredictable that would just throw them
off I bet so one of the takeaways is
that well maybe these questions should
be something that people
decide themselves so if I know that
these are the things that I want to
address later and I could do them in a
car that's what should show up because
then I'm expecting them I already have
the context I just need to get them
recorded somehow and that brings us back
to the foresight and ability to plan
ahead or have enough margin in your day
to have thought through the things you
want to ask yourself when you're in the
car right so one of the things that we
are also looking at is how can we easily
create these micro tasks without
requiring people to again sit down and
then make a list of things that we are
doing well okay Shawn see we've reached
that what could possibly go wrong the
part of the show and I have to ask you
is there anything about your work that
keeps you up at night so let me
contextualize this a little you're
trying to help people be more productive
but let's be honest the quest for
increased productivity can have
unintended consequences we've alluded to
them a little bit earlier for example
this idea that if I can be more
productive I must be more productive and
as you said it isn't just other people
it's our own expectations of ourselves
will I ever be enough right so what is
to keep us from falling into that trap
of the ever moving goal posts are always
asymptotically approaching productive
enough status a probably mentioned this
before is that I find the word
productivity to be very mechanical and
another strand of my research which I
alluded to is work that I have done and
I'm continuing to do with Mary Sharansky
and Gloria mark from UC Irvine where we
are looking at people's ability to focus
at work at the same time how can we
support well-being and what we have
found is brakes are super important I
mean we can't ask people to be
productive all the time because that
doesn't work so if you want to have a
happy productive satisfied worker you
need to be able to support them in a way
that they get things done they get
things done efficiently and that's where
the
system support comes through but they
also are able to take breaks and relax
and be present at things that are not
work be present with their families be
present with their hobbies and not have
to work all the time but I totally hear
you there will be cases where it gets
abused we are working very hard to make
sure that we don't promote that kind of
behavior mm-hmm so there anything else
that comes to your mind that you're
thinking ahead on in this realm aside
from you know the psychological need to
be valuable I guess is a good word so I
think that we need to rethink how we get
things done and we're also not saying
that you don't need focus time you do
need focus time there are certain things
that you cannot do without having focus
time so what we are looking at is that
there is this alternative way of getting
things done and maybe the combination of
both is where we go for the next few
years yeah I'm thinking of surgery you
might micro tasks that you might not
want to do that via micro tasks but
there might be parts of it that are
micro tasks able all right it's story
time okay tell us a bit about yourself
in your background what got young chomps
the iqbal interested in technology
research particularly around attention
multitasking in productivity yeah it's
kind of like a fun pet so I did my
undergrad back in Bangladesh that's
where I grew up I went to a very
traditional engineering program it was
the top engineering program in
Bangladesh but it was very traditional I
had never heard of human-computer
interaction before I started applying
for grad school and then when I came to
grad school in 2002 I came thinking that
I was going to do artificial
intelligence because I liked seeing
patterns in data and that's what I
wanted to work on a new professor came
to our department and gave a talk on
this subject called human-computer
interaction and I went to that talk and
I said oh
that's interesting I mean you can
actually identify problems that humans
care about and then you can come up with
technology solution and you can see
directly that impact so that's where my
work on attention management started so
that's what I've been working on for the
past 17 years there was a jump there and
that's where my interest in attention
management started so what triggered
that because I HCI is a big right pool
so I did skip over a lot of details but
during that path or during that journey
I came to know about the amazing
research that goes on in MSR so
particularly in terms of work that Eric
Horvitz has done and Mary Sharansky has
done and those were the pioneers that I
looked up to and I was extremely lucky
to have an opportunity to do an
internship with Eric in 2006 and 2008
I showed up as a full-timer man I've
been here since then I love this new
question I'm asking because the answers
have really surprised and amazed me so I
would like to ask you what is one
interesting thing whether it's a trade
characteristic or even a life event that
people might not know about you that has
influenced your career as a researcher I
don't know whether this has influenced
my career as a researcher but I used to
be terrified of public speaking and in
some sense I still am a little anxious
before I have to give a big talk and
it's interesting because as a researcher
I have to give talks all the time but I
will be lying if I say that I don't
worry about it
so how have you overcome that so I came
up with coping strategies and one of
them is really silly I start off with a
joke most of the time that joke doesn't
land but at least it comes me down so
I've done that at big talks and it makes
me feel better do you have like a
standard joke no I wing it depending on
what the situation is so I remember once
at Chi
I just messed up at the beginning saying
oh my talk is at 12 a.m. and that was in
a room full of probably 2500 people
because I totally messed up what am was
and PM was so funny and then at the real
talk I said well thank you for all
showing out because I asked everyone to
show up at midnight all right well at
the end of every show I give my guests
an opportunity to share anything they
want with our listeners and often it's
in the form of advice or words of wisdom
so what would you tell your 25 year old
self and how might it apply to others
heading in the same direction now I
would say confidence takes you far
openness takes you in different hats
during that journey and humility keeps
you grounded I have had to work on the
first one the second two are easier for
me Vamsi Iqbal thank you so much for
joining us today it's been a delight
thanks a lot Gretchen it was fun talking
to you
[Music]
to learn more about dr. sharm see iqbal
and the science of micro productivity
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]